Domonique drew a 72 centimeter line on
the playground with blue chalk so the
line that she drew maybe it looks
something like that and that is 72
centimeters 72 centimeters long so from
there to there is 72 centimeters and
another line with pink chalk that is so
let's do this with pink chalk another
line with pink chalk that is 14
centimeters longer than the blue line so
let me draw the other line so the other
line whoops
the other line is going to be 14
centimeters longer so maybe it looks
something like that so it's definitely
going to be longer and it's 14
centimeters longer so if we go from here
to here that's going to be the same so
maybe we make it the same length this is
going to be the 72 centimeters that's 72
centimeters but it's also another 14
centimeters so it's going to be 14
centimeters longer so how long is a pink
chalk line the Domonique drew well you
just add the 72 plus 14 so 72 plus 14 is
equal to 2 ones plus four ones is six
ones seven 10s plus one 10 is eight 10s
so this longer line here is going to be
86 86 centimeters let's do another one
so we're told a cable on the Golden Gate
Bridge is 33 meters long another cable
is 13 meters longer than the first cable
let me do this in a different color
color is 13 meters longer than the first
cable how long would the cables be if
lined up end to end so they're not just
saying how long is the longer one like
they did in the last example they want
to know how long is are the cables if
you line them up end to end
so this first cable is 33 meters we draw
it this way so the first cable is 33
meters long
33 and actually why don't I draw it why
don't I draw it this way because this is
what the cables would actually look like
so this cable is 33 33
meters long another cable is 13 meters
longer than the first cable so this
other cable right over here is 13 meters
longer so this cable right here is 13
meters longer so what's the length of
this cable well it's going to be the
length of the first one 33 plus 13 is 13
meters longer plus 13 that gets us three
plus three is six three plus one is four
this one over here is going to be 46
meters now they didn't just ask how long
is the second cable which is 46 meters
they're asking how long would the cables
be if we line them up end to end so if
we line to the 33 meter one so if we
lined up the 33 meter one and then right
next to that we right next to that put
the 46 meter one so if we did something
like that well we know that this one
over here is 33 meters and the next one
is 46 meters so we would have to add 33
plus 46 to figure out how long they
would be end to end and what is that
going to be so we say 33 plus 46 plus 46
three ones plus six ones is nine ones
three tens plus four tens is 79 three
tens plus four tens is seven tens so
it's going to be 79 meters if we line
them up and to end let's do one more
Reynaldo has a 36 centimeter scarf so he
has a 36 centimeter scarf he decides to
cut out part of the scarf so it is now
only 19 centimeters
how many centimeters did Reynaldo cut
off of his scarf so let's draw his scarf
so it was a 36 centimeter scarf so it
might have looked something like this
so this was his scarf before if I
stretch it all out and it is 36
centimeters 36 centimeters long and but
he cuts part of his scarf so it's only
19 centimeters long so now it is only 19
centimeters so it's going to after he
cut it it's going to look something like
this it's actually maybe I'll actually
I'll draw it in green
again so after he cuts it his scarf is
going to look something like this it's
going to look something like this where
now it's only 19 centimeters 19
centimeters so how much did he cut off
well what he cut off is going to be the
difference between 36 and 19 he would
have cut to cut off he would have to cut
off all of this right over here in order
to get it down to 19 so how much would
he have to cut off well this right over
here is going to be 36 minus 19 it's the
difference between 36 and 19 so let's
figure out let's figure out what that is
it's going to be 36 minus 19 so let's
see if we we have six ones we want to
take away nine one so let's do a little
bit of regrouping let's take one of our
tens here so instead of three tens we
have two tens and then if we add that 10
to the ones place instead of six ones
we're going to have 16 ones 16 minus 9
is 7
two tens minus 1/10 is 1/10 so he would
have had to cut off 17 centimeters of
his scarf if he started with 36
centimeters he cuts off 17 centimeters
he's going to be left with 19
centimeters and you could you could do
that the other way around you could
start with 36 you could cut 17 and see
what you end up with you're going to see
that you end up with 19